bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
en direct sur figaro l'arrivée sur
youtube il y à 40 ans le premier tgv
relier paris à lyon et cet été c'était
exactement le 22 septembre
1981 et ce premier tgv permis de
rejoindre lyon depuis paris en 2 heures
40 minutes contre 4 heures par avant la
sncf débutent les célébrations de ce
40ème 40e anniversaire aujourd'hui en
gare de lyon en présence du chef de
l'état emmanuel macron et dans quelques
minutes nous vous ferons découvrir en
direct sur figaro live le tgv du futur
pour commenter cette actualité en direct
avec nous ce matin nous avons le plaisir
d'être avec françois de l'e3 journaliste
au figaro magazine bonjour françois
bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
ce matin vous êtes et on va expliquer
aux attendant pourquoi vous êtes dans le
noir vous êtes en direct avec nous
depuis le canada ce qui explique que
pour vous il est excessivement tôt et
donc c'est encore la pleine nuit
exactement je suis au canada pour une
raison toute simple c'est pour le une
enquête pour le figaro sur le nouvel
airbus à 220 dont air france reprend son
premier exemplaire à la fin du mois et
qui est un avion qui fait 25 % de
consommation qui arrosait dans mois et
donc 25 % d'émissions de co2 en moins et
surtout 50 pour chante de bruit de moins
que tous ses concurrents eh bien nous
verrons ça dans vos papiers qui
sortiront j'imagine dans quelques jours
à ce propos pour l'instant on revient
sur terre et sur les voies ferrées en
france avec le tgv dont on parle
aujourd'hui puisque c'est son
quarantième anniversaire célébré en
direct depuis la gare de lyon dans
quelques minutes en présence du chef de
l'état françois je vous remercie encore
d'être avec nous de répondre aux
internautes et aux internautes justement
va n'hésitez pas à nous poster vos
commentaires vos témoignages aussi
peut-être vos souvenirs en tgv ce que
vous pensez du tgv et du futur tgv le
tgv m dont on vous reparlera dans
quelques minutes françois je vous je me
tourne de nouveau vers vous j'ai d'abord
envie de vous demander à vous si il ya
40 ans ou s'il ya une quarantaine
d'années vous êtes vous même monté dans
ce tgv dont on se souvient qu'il était
orange à l'époque et si vous avez un
souvenir concret à nous partager
alors le premier souvenir qu'on a dû tgv
s'éveille évidemment sa couleur et puis
le deuxième souvenir qu'on inquiète très
étonnant c'est que la sncf avait fait
une publicité à l'époque avec des vaches
dans un pré qui tournait la tête comme
ça tac tac tac en voyant enfin pour
montrer sa vitesse à l'époque il ne
faisait que du 260 km/heure alors
qu'aujourd'hui les tgv sont à 3 103 110
donc vous voyez que on a gagné du temps
depuis cette époque là mais par rapport
à l'ancien train qui passait par dijon
et par la voie normale
le tgv a été vraiment un
plus pour les passagers
la sncf avait hésité pendant un temps à
faire comme ce que faisait les italiens
l'époque c'est à dire de se dire est-ce
qu'on améliore la voie existante et est
ce qu'on achète un train qui peut faire
du 200 km h sur une voie normale est en
fait ce qui a poussé à la décision de la
création du tgv c'est que la voie entre
paris et lyon était totalement saturé et
qu'il fallait de toute façon créer une
nouvelle
une nouvelle voie et que le deuxième
chose qui a poussé la sncf faire c'est
que la nouvelle voix fait 80 km de moins
que l'ancienne voie mais la sncf à
l'époque avait été autorisée à tarifer
le prix du tgv comme s'ils roulaient sur
l'ancienne voie donc comme s'il faisait
catherine 80 km de plus on va revenir
françois sur les bouleversements dont ce
train a été à l'origine ces trains à
grande vitesse a été à l'origine en
france avant j'aimerais quand même qu'on
revienne sur ses origines vous en avez
évoqué quelques unes j'aimerais savoir
pourquoi et on aimerait comprendre
comment il est né ce tgv à quelle époque
il a été
pensé et conçu quelle était la stratégie
de départ de lancer un train à grande
vitesse en france est-ce qu'il
s'agissait de développer on va dire le
transport ferroviaire ou ou tout
simplement de de tisser un inde
d'améliorer et de développer
économiquement les territoires en france
alors
les premières questions qui sont posées
c'est évidemment là la problématique de
la saturation de la ligne entre paris et
lyon qui était la plus grosse ligne de
france et alors ce moment les ingénieurs
se sont posé la question de savoir est
ce qui faisait un train qui roulait sur
des voies normales c'est à dire des voix
avec un écartement normal ou alors la
grande tendance à l'époque c'était
d'essayer d'imaginer un nouveau train
gens l'aérotrain ou à train à
sustentation magnétique et c est le seul
exemple de qu'on avait dans le monde
deux trains à grande vitesse sur voie
normale c'était le train japonais le
shinkansen
la sncf et alstom à l'époque ont décidé
de choisir les voies normales pour une
raison toute simple c'est que ça
limiter fortement les investissements
puisqu'on avait que la voie nouvelle
affaire et quand on sortait de la
nouvelle voie on allait sur les voies
normales pour aller en gare et surtout
ça permettait d'avoir une la grande
vitesse sur une partie de la de la ligne
et ensuite d'aller plus loin sur les
voies normales donc en fait c'était ça a
été presque un réflexe économique de
faire le tgv tel qu'on le connaît nous
en france peut-être appelé à nos
internautes 1 pour faire un petit saut
en arrière dans le temps que c'est ce
tgv train à grande vitesse a été lancé
par georges pompidou il a été construit
sous valéry giscard d'estaing et puis il
a été inauguré par françois mitterrand
le 22 septembre 1981 quarante ans plus
tard eh bien nous sommes là le tgv
existe encore et puis un nouveau tgv
devrait être lancée avec science 2024 on
enverra le modèle tout à l'heure en
direct dans quelques minutes il sera
dévoilé par emmanuel mâcon qui se
trouvera dans quelques minutes en direct
depuis la garde des lieux garde tout est
parti d'où est partie la première
liaison de tgv entre paris et lyon
justement ce 22 septembre 80 on vous
fera vivre tout ça dans quelques minutes
nous sommes en direct sur figaro live et
sur youtube avec françois de letras
journaliste au figaro magazine et
spécialiste des transports il est en
direct depuis le canada pour nous ce
matin et il est là pour vous pour
répondre à toutes vos questions et vos
commentaires donc vous n'hésitez pas à
nous faire part de ce que vous pensez du
tgv si vous me prenez régulièrement si
vous avez des souvenirs de 40 ans qu'on
ce tgv ceram orange traverser la
campagne française voilà on attend vos
commentaires sur youtube et sur figaro
live françois
on parlait de co2 cette origine ses
origines du train à grande vitesse en
france le fait que pour des questions
économiques on est resté on a conçu un
train qui a pouvait circuler sur les
voies ferrées telle qu'elle existait à
l'époque
est ce que il y avait aussi l'ambition
de développer les territoires d'un point
de vue économique on imagine que oui que
l'arrivée du tgv dans certaines gares et
dans certaines villes a suscité sur ces
40 dernières années un boom économique
dans certains coins
alors le tgv au départ n'avait pas du
tout la prétention de desservir les
territoires c'était uniquement une
quelque chose de pratique pour la sncf
c'est à dire de désengorger la ligne
paris-lyon et surtout de gagner de
l'argent parce que paris lyon c'est
quand même la ligne la plus rentable de
france la preuve c'est qu'aujourd'hui la
concurrence ou est ce qu'elle va elle va
sur paris lyon on en parlera tout à
l'heure
il s'est avéré que la desserte des plus
fine des territoires avec des jets v2
des tgv qui allait jusqu'à annecy
jusqu'à chambéry jusqu'à grenoble a
permis le développement de ces régions
là qu'ils étaient mal desservies ou avec
qu'il est desservie avec beaucoup plus
de temps par la sncf
la question se pose aujourd'hui de
savoir si ces desserts sont toujours
rentable ou pas parce que vous savez que
sur les 220 les quelques 200
villes desservies par le tgv la moitié
des destinations coûte de l'argent à la
sncf elle ne gagne pas d'argent
on a une question françois d'un
internaute sur le chat du figaro c'est
alex 87 qu'on salue bien sûr aller 87
nous demande une du bonjour le tgv du
futur pourra t'il se passer
d'électricité nucléaire pour être
compétitif vaste question françois est
ce que vous pouvez répondre à alex 87
bien sûr le tgv du futur comme au tgv
d'aujourd'hui pourrait se passer de
l'électricité nucléaire d'ailleurs la
sncf met un point d'honneur à
ceux sur plan marketing à dire que c'est
à que le train et et moins consommateurs
d'énergie et surtout moins émetteurs de
co2 et que pour cela ils essayent dans
la mesure du possible de se fournir en
énergie verte mais que ce soit le tgv
d'aujourd'hui le tgv de demain la
problématique est la même c'est il faut
trouver l'énergie verte l'avantagent du
tgv du futur c'est qu'ils consomment 25
% d'électricité en moins que le tgv
d'aujourd'hui
si vous nous rejoignez en direct sur
figaro live nous sommes avec vous pour
vous faire vivre le 40e anniversaire du
tgv depuis la gare de lyon où devrait se
présenter dans quelques minutes
maintenant emmanuel macron il dévoilera
le nouveau tgv le tgv m il va lancer les
célébrations de ce 40e anniversaire à la
télé là tu es la sncf fait les choses en
grand je crois qu'il y aura une maquette
grandeur nature de la motrice du tgv m
pour montrer au public elle sera visible
par le public à partir d'aujourd'hui
pour quelques jours ce tgv s'appelle on
l'appelle un peu
de façon un peu clin d'oeil à certains
films tgv du futur il s'appelle en fait
tgv m pourquoi d'ailleurs françois des
traces tgv m c'est une histoire de
modernité de mobilité que voulait mettre
en avant la sncf avec ses surnoms way à
peu près mais ce qu'il faut surtout dire
c'est que la sentra à lui un cahier des
charges c'est-à-dire moins d'électricité
plus de passagers à bord
et qu'elle a données ce cahier des
charges à alstom et c'est alstom qui
fabrique le tracé pas la sncf
et alstom évidemment c'est bien sûr que
c'est alstom qui fabrique que ce train
et qui le fabrique depuis depuis
quarante ans maintenant
et la sncf je le disais compte mettre
sur ses rails en 2024 ce tgv m donc
fabriquées par alstom vous dites que il
est plus rapide ce train qui serait mis
en circulation en 1024 y norma km heure
c'est ça
la rend la rapidité des trains on sait
faire d'eux des trains plus rapides le
problème c'est les voies et
est aujourd'hui avec les voit qu'on a et
les précautions qu'il faut prendre on
veut pas aller au delà de 300 320
kilomètres heure mais vous savez qu'il
s'était garé à gagner le record du monde
de vitesse ferroviaire avec 540 km h il
ya quelques années c'est ça peut pas
être des vitesses commerciales ça vous
rendez compte avec le souffle que ça
représente un train qui passe à 300 km h
si on le faisait passer à 500 il faut
écarter les voix il faut mettre une
double des barbelés de chaque côté et
c'est impossible mais pour être très
précise françois le tgv a battu son
record de vitesse
en 2007 lors d'un essai on est arrivé à
une pointe de 575 km heure est donc
comme vous le précisez c'est évidemment
pas une vitesse de croisière ou de
vitesse en
alors des connexions commercial lors des
transports commerciaux c'est juste
comment on peut dire ça que c'est une
prouesse technique pour montrer la
technologie et l'efficacité des motrices
de tgv française oui mais pour manque la
stabilité du train le prix qu'il pouvait
rester sur les voies sans bouger etc
les internautes ont peut-être en mémoire
l'histoire de l'accident du tgv espagnol
où il y avait un conducteur qui
s'amusaient à faire des records de
vitesse pour lui-même et qu'il émettait
sur youtube et puis un jour il a fait un
record de vitesse et le tracé le le
train est parti dans les décors parce
qu'elle est trop vite c'est que les voix
pouvait pas supporter
on va citer pour nos internautes
quelques quelques chiffres clés un prêt
de 3 milliards de voyageurs ont voyagé
avec le tgv depuis 1940 1981 donc depuis
40 ans le milliard de voyageurs avait
été atteint en 2003 les deux milliards
en 2012 on voit que on a un laps de
temps encore plus rapide on a atteint 3
milliards beaucoup de voyageurs
circulant en train aujourd'hui le train
on peut le dire a supplanté l'avion en
tout cas sur sûre en tout cas en france
pour les connexions en métropole alors
non pas encore et ça c'est une des
erreurs de dia quelques années de la
sncf qui voulait qu'ils pensaient que
son concurrent c'était l'avion ils ont
changé de stratégie
récemment et ils savent que maintenant
leur concurrencer la voiture la fonction
de l'avion et la fonction du train n'est
pas la même le train il peut s'arrêter
en route et faire ce qu'on appelle du
cabotage c'est par exemple quand vous
allez de paris à marseille le travail
peut s'arrêter à mâcon il se peut
s'arrêter à valence il peut s'arrêter à
avignon chose qu'on ne peut pas faire
l'avion donc l'idée de la sncf au départ
de faire ce qu'on appelle du point à
point c'est à dire d'aller d'une grande
ville à une autre grande ville sans
s'arrêter du tout et était une erreur
qui est en train d'être corrigées en se
disant que le train il est aussi là pour
desservir les territoires et le rôle de
l'avion c'est d'aller dam d'un endroit à
l'autre le plus rapidement possible
sachant que l'avion consomment moins
et mais moins de co2 que quelqu'un en
voiture
c'est effectivement un avantage
considérable qui est mis largement en
avant aujourd'hui avec les
considérations climatique et le
réchauffement climatique
les impératifs écologiques le train
devient le moyen de transport le plus
écologique face en particulier à la
voiture qui représente quand même la
majorité des déplacements sur notre
territoire
merci à tous 1 debout suivre en direct
sur figaro là il va sur youtube je veux
te demandes comment ces questions à nous
faire part de votre témoignage nous
allons je vais les relayer auprès de
françois de l'etrat ce qui est en direct
avec nous depuis le canada alors que
vous voyez sur ces images des images
d'archivés du tgv de ce premier tgv
à cette couleur si symbolique et cette
couleur orange je crois me souvenir
françois que la première rame ou la
première motrice du tgv s'appelait
patrick on l'appelait patrick vous savez
pourquoi non je ne sais pas je crois que
c'était le prénom d'un du fils du
premier conducteur du tgv je crois
c'était un petit clin d'oeil rendit à 7
à cet enfant et à son et à son papa
conducteurs de train voilà on voit ces
belles images d archives du tgv et puis
on voit maintenant cette trame est ce
que ce sont des images ne sont pas des
images en direct sont des images
d'archivés donc on cette petite maquette
modèle réduit du tgv orange avec le tgv
tel qu'on le connaît aujourd'hui on voit
la motrice en arrière plan avec les
couleurs les codes couleur fuchsia et
gris et blanc et le duplex des rames de
tgv convoi en arrière-plan voilà
françoise et les trajets quelques
questions à vous poser de la part
d'internautes qui sont connectés sur sur
lefigaro.fr alex
93-87 qui nous a posé une question tout
à l'heure sur
l'électricité nucléaire et la
compétitivité du tgv à une autre un
témoignage cette fois-ci dont ils
souhaitent nous faire par expérience
personnelle dit il en tgv je me suis
toujours senti comment comme dans un
ascenseur horizontal dit il plus que
dans un train car le tgv glisse ça aussi
c'est une prouesse du tgv de ne pas de
en tout cas de supprimer ou d'atténuer
considérablement le roulis ou en tout
cas le bruit des roues sur les rails on
a l'impression d'être sur des pneus
alors on s'est un peu c'est un peu à
cause du tgv mais c'est surtout à cause
des voix
quand on a une voix moderne
très bien entretenu et c'est il ya
brillé à moins de chocs et on a on a 12
cette impression de
glisser plus que je voulais et en plus
la deuxième paie de la deuxième chose
importante c'est que sur les voies
nouvelles il ya très peu d'aiguillage
parce que on traverse pas des vies non
travers on est en pleine campagne alors
que sur une voie normale il ya
énormément d'aiguillage qui eux font des
chocs du oui
donc c'est moins la technologie des
rames du train que celle des voies
ferrées c'est ça que vous nous dites
françois exactement
sur le chat youtube du figaro live vous
êtes également en train de nous faire
part de vos commentaires et vos
questions jérôme bougeons bonjour un
super train le tgv mais est-ce qu'un
hyper loupé c'est pour bientôt on va
peut-être préciser ce qu'est un hyper
loupe pour ceux qui nous suivent
françois hyper look c'est le projet de
jeu musclé l'aude musk
qui voudraient créer des tuyaux
s'empressant pressurisation dans le
temps dans lequel le train avant serait
coma comme un boulet de canon
c'est très compliqué à réaliser il faut
que le tuyau soit totalement étanche et
surtout ça ne permet c'est ce qu'ont
expliqué tout à l'heure ça ne permet que
d'aller d'un point à un autre
si prisé il voudrait c'est très sain
entre san francisco et los angeles
ça ne servira que le point d'arrivée le
point départ et ça pourra pas aller sur
les voies normales pour desservir des
gares etc etc donc c'est un projet
volant si ça se fait un jour c'est
pendant cinq ans touchant temps
c'est pas tout de suite donc en
attendant on va utiliser la technologie
coco des biens en l'occurrence les voies
ferrées et les rames de train nous
sommes en direct à l'éden park
les gens ne se rendent pas compte que
c'est déjà très compliqué de faire
rouler un train c'est plus compliqué de
faire rouler un train que de faire voler
un avion pourquoi parce que le train il
est à terre
à terre il peut y avoir un incendie il
peut y avoir un sanglier qui passe il
peut y avoir un suicide ip il ya mille
raisons pour lequel c'est compliqué de
faire rouler un train alors que de faire
voler un avion c'est compliqué à
l'arrivée c'est compliqué au départ mais
entre les deux c'est exceptionnel qui
est quelque chose qui se passe tout à
l'heure vous vous parliez à propos de la
vitesse du tgv qui si elle l était
constante à 500 et quelques km heure
seraient
mettrait le train dans une telle
situation et ses passagers dans une
telle situation et l'environnement dans
de telles conditions qu'on serait obligé
de protéger les voies à limites sur
l'ensemble du territoire aujourd'hui on
s'interroge quand même parfois on se
fait la réflexion voies des trains à
grande vitesse passé en pleine campagne
a pas de protection particulière des
voix on s'étonne qu'il n'y ait pas plus
souvent peut-être qu'on en n'a pas
connaissance des obstacles qui sont
sciemment ou involontairement placé sur
les voies comment comment la sncf peut
contrôler les 2600 je crois ou 2900
kilomètres de voies rapides du train tgv
sur le territoire français pour éviter
justement les accidents alors les voies
rapides sont toutes protégées par un
grillage
tout le long en plus dans tout les
territoires elle pas s'il ya des animaux
il ya des tunnels qui ont été créées
sous les voies pour que les animaux ne
s'attaque pas au grillage mais passent
dessous ceci dit il faut quand même dire
une chose très importante et que la sncf
ne dit pas pour des raisons
comment vous dit comment dire pour pas
que ça ne faut pas que ça fasse un effet
de mode si et qu'il ya quand même sur
les voies ferrées françaises un suicide
par jour
donc c'est énorme c'est ce qu'on appelle
un accident de personne donc et un
accident de personne ça mais la voix ça
provoque un retard d'environ trois
heures pour tous les trains qui sont
derrière vous voyez de la problématique
d'être sur terre est quand même très
compliqué en plus alors les voir
contrairement aux voies normales qui
sont elles
une distance de protection sur les côtés
qui est de quelques mètres pour les
voies tgv la protection est beaucoup
plus grave beaucoup plus grande donc il
n'est pas question qu'un arbre tombe sur
la voie cela était très attention à ça
c'est françois des les phrases qui vous
répond en direct sur figaro l'avait sur
youtube il est journaliste au figaro
magazine et il est avec nous en direct
pour vous répondre et nous commenter et
commenter avec nous les images que nous
allons recevoir dans quelques minutes
des célébrations du 40e anniversaire du
tgv qui vont se passer en gare de lyon
la gare de lyon c'est la gare d'origine
du tgv lors de sa première liaison entre
paris et lyon le tgv est parti de la
gare de lyon et c'est là que se rendre à
emmanuel macron dans quelques minutes
pour lancer ces célébrations il nous
révélera également le nouveau tgv le tgv
m à propos duquel d'ailleurs françois un
internaute du figaro live s'interrogent
ils s'appellent saas 1 et ils nous
demandent quels sont les avantages de
ces nouvelles rames de trains de ce
nouveau tgv
pour les voyageurs
pour les voyageurs le premier avantage
c'est d'avoir plus de place à bord
pour la sncf le gros avantage c'est de
mettre plus de passagers à bord et
précis ne sais pas si c'est dû à une
consommation de d'électricité réduite de
30% donc ça fait plusieurs avantages
importants vous savez pour les passagers
la problématique des bus des bagages
dans le tgv qui s'assoit et tgv duplex
ou le tgv normal est un est un vrai
souci
c'est quelque chose auquel alstom avait
pas pensé au départ
les voyageurs ont des bagages ils en ont
parfois beaucoup
surtout pour l'aider des distances
longues et donc ça cette problématique
là va être corrigé dans le dans le
nouveau tgv à titre d'exemple thalys qui
relient le train le tgv qui relie paris
bruxelles amsterdam et cologne a été
obligée d'enlever des sièges pour
rajouter des d'irak à bagages pour que
les jambes pour que les couloirs ne soit
pas encombrée par les valises ça veut
dire que les voyageurs qui jusqu'à
présent devaient abandonner entre
guillemets à leur envoyer leurs bagages
au bout du wagon pourront les avoir à
proximité de leurs sièges c'est ça non
non c'est pas ça simplement que les
espaces consacrés aux bagages sont
beaucoup plus grands que dans le tgv
qu'on connaît oui ou c'est toujours
difficile de placer les bagages au
dessus de nos têtes c'est ça
en préparant cette émission je lisais
l'interview
de quelqu'un qui
expliqué qu' on pouvait considérer
le tgv comme un fleuron industriel
un pur produit de l'ingénierie française
au même titre que le nucléaire ou la
fusée ariane
au même titre que le nucléaire est
rapide hier à ne pas tout à fait la
grosse différence c'est que le tgv on a
énormément de mal à le vendre à
l'étranger
il ya très peu de pays qui l'ont acheté
regardez les allemands ils ont créé leur
propre est ce qu'on appelle lycée eux
les seuls pays qui l'ont acheté c'est
l'espagne la corée est maintenant le
maroc avec une grosse aide française
donc c'est pas un succès c'est pas un
succès international contrairement au
nucléaire ou à la fusée ariane
je le disais en lançant cette émission
et à plusieurs reprises déjà on attend
l'arrivée d'emmanuel maquereau en gare
de lyon pour le lancement des
célébrations du 40e anniversaire du tgv
qui ont lieu donc à partir d'aujourd'hui
en gare de lyon à paris
il dévoilera pour pour l'occasion le tgv
du futur il sera accompagné de trois
ministres barbara pompili la ministre la
transition écologique bruno le maire
-ministre de l'économie et jean baptiste
djebbari le ministre des transports
françois de l'e3 emmanuel macron
avait un peu remis en question au début
de son quinquennat en 2017 le
développement du tgv et puis de nouveau
et bien il remet en selle avec donc
cette nouvelle rame et puis possiblement
de l'ouverture de nouvelles lignes
commencent explique le revirement du
chef de l'état et cet intérêt nouveau
pour les lignes à grande vitesse en
france quel est l'intérêt derrière tout
ça
c'est la pression politique c'est que
les élus locaux ont pas compris que
l'amélioration des lignes quotidiennes
et des lignes normales avait pour les
passagers plus davantage que la création
de nouvelles lignes qui coûtent des
fortunes regardez ce qui se passe à
toulouse
ils sont tous en train de monter au
créneau pour obtenir le bout de ligne
entre bordeaux et toulouse alors que
l'urgence c'est de régler la
problématique du de l'encombrement des
voies la sortie de toulouse et
l'encombrement des voies à la sortie à
l'entrée bordeaux la création de la
ligne entre bordeaux et toulouse va
évidemment améliorer le temps de
distance entre toulouse et paris d'une
heure et entre bordeaux et montpellier
d'une heure aussi mais c'est pas ça qui
va régler la problématique des passagers
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment les élus
locaux pensent que le tgv c'est la
solution alors qu'elle ne l'est pas
alex 87 sur le chat et figaro.fr à une
autre question à vous poser françois
quel est le coût pour le contribuable du
tgv m donc ce nouveau tgv qui sera mis
en route en tout cas a mis sur les rails
à partir de 2024 autrement dit nous
précise-t-il quelle est la part des
capitaux privés dans son développement
est ce qu'on est capable de répondre
alex 4
le tgv est
tout le monde dit toujours la sncf est
subventionné par l'état à l'iphone il
faut séparer les choses et tout ce qui
est grandes lignes c'est à dire tout ce
qui était gvt et n'est absolument pas
subventionnés par l'état et donc la
création du télé du tgv m fait partie du
budget de recherche et développement
d'alstom en prévision qui a fait ça
parce qu'elle sait que la sncf va lui
acheter un certain nombre de rames
derrière qui vont équilibrer ses comptes
l'état n'intervient absolument pas dans
le financement de ce développement
on le voit en ce moment sur les images
que vous nous que nous vous diffusons il
s'agit des images de paris gare de lyon
on se déroule en ce moment l'arrivée des
invités et du public pour le lancement
du 40e anniversaire
de ce tgv qui a fait sa première liaison
paris lyon le 22 septembre 1981 en
présence de françois mitterrand vous le
voyez on voit des personnels de bord de
la sncf devant une rame de tgv avec un
du public on attend l'arrivée d'
emmanuel macron
accompagné de trois de ses ministres
babara pompili bruno le maire jean
baptiste djebbari
le chef de l'état emmanuel macron
devrait dévoiler les nouvelles rames du
tgv m tgv m pour modernité mobilité
c
image donc sont diffusées en direct
depuis la gare de lyon et nous vous en
dirons plus dès que elles nous
permettront de voir l'arrivée du chef de
l'état nous parlions françois del et
rase du développement de nouvelles
lignes à grande vitesse à horizon 2030
on parle d'un développement d'une ligne
sur bordeaux toulouse nice marseille
montpellier béziers que faut-il penser
de de ses possibles nouvelles lignes à
grande vitesse est ce que l'échéance
2030 2035 vous paraît réaliste et puis
combien vont coûter c'est ces nouvelles
connexions ces nouvelles lignes de
trains à grande vitesse parce que je
crois qu'au km on est sur des budgets de
plusieurs dizaines de millions d'euros
tout à fait alors sur les trois lignes
qui sont prévues il y en a une qui est
indispensable c'est la ligne entre
montpellier et béziers
parce que le la ligne normale est
totalement saturé et que on ne respecte
pas les engagements qu'on avait pris
avec les espagnols de créer une ligne à
grande vitesse jusqu'à la frontière les
espagnols ont créé la ligne à grande
vitesse de figueras à barcelone et la
france pour la france la ligne s'arrête
à montpellier dont il reste le tronçon
montpellier perpignan a terminé pour que
le réseau à grande vitesse espagnol qui
est le plus grand d'europe maintenant
ils nous ont dépassés
soit en liaison avec le réseau à grande
vitesse français donc le petit bout
montpellier béziers va permettre de
désengorger la ligne normale donc
d'améliorer les trains du quotidien les
ter qui passe sur cette ligne est de
gagner un quart d'heure de temps ce qui
permettra de mettre
montpellier à moins de trois heures de
barcelone ça c'est la première
ligne qui est indispensable la deuxième
qui verra le jour c'est celle entre
bordeaux et toulouse donc comme je vous
le disais tout à l'heure la
problématique c'est l'entrée et la
sortie de toulouse l'entrée et la sortie
de bordeaux qui sont excessivement
saturé mais les élus locaux
plaident pour une nouvelle ligne entre
bordeaux et toulouse et je pense que le
gouvernement a cédé
sachant que pour la sncf il n'est pas
sûr que la ligne soit très rentable
après cela viendra la ligne anne horizon
plus lointain entre nice et marseille
alors l'appareil en à deux
problématiques c'est la sortie et
l'entrée de marseille la sortie et
l'entrée de nice qui d'eux qu'ils sont
frais dans un premier temps et après ça
la ligne se fera dans le sens nice
marseille c'est à dire par tronçon on
fera d'abord le tronçon de nice et de
cannes et et ainsi de suite sachant que
la ligne de bord de mer qui superbe et
elle totalement saturée aussi on peut
plus un peu puis ajoutez deux trains
malgré
une technologie mode moderne ce qu'on
arrive à ajouter serait minime
alors que vous le voyez ces images
diffusées en direct depuis paris et la
gare de lyon voix bruno le maire qui
fait des selphy avec le personnel de la
sncf on a vu barbara pompili également
et jean baptiste djebbari qui sont donc
arrivés à côté de cette rame de tgv pour
lancer les célébrations du 40e
anniversaire du tgv donc 2 qui avait
fait sa première liaison paris gare de
lyon paris lyon pardon le 22 septembre
1981 c'est le chef de l'état emmanuel
macron qui devrait maintenant arriver
en attendant je vous livre quelques
commentaires d'internautes qui nous
suivent en ce moment en direct sur
figaro.fr le figaro.fr figaro live et la
chaîne figaro live sur youtube djédjé 0
1 qui nous disent et jason en australie
ici bravo la sncf 40 ans de tgv c'est
absolument incroyable la fierté de la
technologie ferroviaire française
sur le chat du figaro.fr
valent pas eu 34 nous dit et ça c'est
une question pour vous françois alex il
répond un internaute il me semble qu
alstom a sorti un train à hydrogène
oui tout à fait mais c'est pas un à
grande vitesse et un train ces points un
ter il est déjà en exploitation dans le
nord de l'allemagne
alstom est le premier constructeur
ferroviaire à faire un travail à
hydrogène et ya plusieurs régions
françaises qui sont intéressés pour
acheter quelques trains en particulier
par exemple l'occitanie et on verra des
trains hydrogène en france d'ici 4-5 ans
alors qu'on voit sur ces images le
ministre des transports jean baptiste
djebbari qui vient d'arriver à côté de
cette rame de tgv je le disais il n'est
pas très loin de barbara pompili et de
bruno le maire qui sont également
présents pour ces célébrations du 40e
anniversaire du tgv
l'intérêt de l'hydrogène c'est pour les
dinky sont pas électrifiés vous savez
qu'en région il ya énormément de ligne
ter qui marche encore avec du diesel est
donc l'intérêt de d'hydrogène c'est
d'avoir des trains à zéro émission de
carbone sur des lignes qui sont pas
électrifiés le trail d'origine n'a aucun
intérêt sur les lignes déjà électrifié
alors il ya une petite remarque d'un
internaute sur
lefigaro.fr qui nous disent et guy qui
nous dit le tgv du futur c'est le tgv
qui arrive déjà à l'heure on va déjà
commencer par ça après on verra c'est
vrai que parmi les critiques qui ont été
faites au tgv c'est aussi des histoires
de d'horaires et parfois les retards
dont souffre le
les lignes à grande vitesse qu'est-ce
qu'on peut répondre alex à guy par
donguy fox alors la problématique du
retard sur une problématique ferroviaire
s'est pas uniquement les tgv les
intercités ont des problèmes les ter ont
des problèmes si on compare avec deux
pays il ya la suisse qui a zéro retard
et l'allemagne qui a énormément de
retard donc vous voyez qu'on peut cesser
des problèmes d'organisation après de
maintien de maintenance des voies de
maintenance des rames
il a il arrive par exemple qu'en région
il ya des terreurs qui sert en retard
parce que le conducteur est pas là qu'il
est sur un autre train que l'autre train
du retard oui en cascade donc la
problématique du retard c'est vraiment
une problématique d'organisation
on le voit sur les images que nous
diffusons en ce moment en direct depuis
la gare de lyon trois ministres du
gouvernement sont arrivés bruno le maire
barbara pompili et jean baptiste
djebbari sont déjà présents on attend
l'arrivée d'emmanuel macron qui lancera
les célébrations du 40e anniversaire du
tgv
françois on sait que l'opérateur
national de la sncf en l'occurrence va
perdre son monopole qu'est ce que ça
veut dire exactement et concrètement
alors il ya deux cas de figure très
différent il ya le cas de figure des
régions pour les ter et le cas de figure
de la grande ligne
pour les régions c'est les régions qui
attribue des lots après des appels
d'offres à la sncf ou à d'autres
opérateurs on a le cas de paca qui vient
d'attribuer deux lots la ligne nice
marseille à une autre entreprise est le
cas de miss les toiles qu'à gagner la
sncf dans l'est dans les hauts de france
il y à une concurrence qui rock est en
train d'être mise en place et dans le
grand est aussi en revanche sur les
grandes lignes c'est d'aider les lignes
tgv ou les lignes intercités
les opérateurs sont libres de faire des
demandes de créneaux pour ouvrir des
lignes et donc là à l'heure actuelle en
a un exemple c'est trenitalia les
italiens qui veulent exploiter deux fois
par jour une ligne entre paris lyon
milan turin
est ce que ça veut dire que la
technologie alstom ne sera plus la seule
à circuler sur les voies ferrées
françaises
alors pas vraiment parce que les
italiens
vous savez qu enfin la sncf c'est
pourquoi est ce que les italiens
reviennent en français il ya une raison
toute simple c'est que la sncf en
a créé il ya quelques années une
entreprise en italie qui s'appelle ntv
avec des tgv d'alstom pour faire de la
grande vitesse entre milan et rome
volition ils sont sortis de cette
expérience là mais quand même les gens
de les gens de trenitalia avait très mal
pris que la sncf viennent sur leurs
plates-bandes et ça c'est de la
technologie alstom et l'autre exemple
qu'on a c'est la reine fait donc les
espagnols qui exploite des tgv d'alstom
et qui veulent ouvrir des lignes entre
lui lyon marseille et barcelone et là ça
sera aussi avec des tgv alstom
toute façon il faut pour pouvoir
exploiter en france il faut passer par
le processus de certification c'est
toute la problématique de l'europe
contrairement à l'aviation on a une
réglementation européenne
pour le ferroviaire chaque pays a sa
propre réglementation donc il faut que
quand vous voulez exploiter un prêt en
france il faut que le train que vous
utilisez
soit certifié par la france et par
l'italie et par l'allemagne donc vous
voyez la problématique de thalys qui
roule sur dans quatre pays différents
c'est à dire allemagne belgique hollande
allemagne
france ils ont été obligés d'avoir des
trains qu'ils soient certifiés dans les
quatre pays et donc que ce soit de
l'alstom moine un autre toute façon les
trains de l'opérateur doivent être
certifiés par la france comment on va
faire la sncf pour garder un maximum de
parts de marché face à face à cette
concurrence qui arrive sur le réseau
ferré français est là de l allant chez
déjà deux produits qui pour essayer
d'empêcher les concurrents de venir elle
l a lancé we go donc le tgv low cost
pour empêcher un concurrent de faire du
low cost et puis surtout en ce moment il
crié une offensive commerciale colossale
sur ce qu'on appelle les cartes avantage
parce qu'ils savent que les gens qui ont
des cartes auront plutôt tendance à
choisir les trains sncf on était en
fidélisant les clients que un autre
train si on prend l'exemple du paris
lyon milan que va ouvrir que vont ouvrir
les italiens deux fois par jour quand la
sncf veut avoir 20 25 liaisons
quotidiennes c'est sûr qu'ils auront du
mal en revanche il risque de piquer la
sncf un certain nombre de passagers
occasionnels
qui veulent voyager dans d'autres
conditions et donc ce petit écrémage de
deux trains par jour peu le peut lui
faire du mal il faut se souvenir que par
exemple si on prend l'exemple avec
l'aérien air france avait autrefois six
à sept liaisons par jour avec milan
easyjet a commencé avec une liaison par
jour et aujourd'hui d'easyjet ils sont à
cinq six liaisons par jour en temps
normal un pas entendre covin avec milan
donc vous voyez qu'au fil du temps la
outsider peut prendre des parts de
marché très importante
merci de nous rejoindre en direct sur
figaro live et le chat
et la chaîne figaro live sur youtube
nous sommes en direct depuis la gare de
lyon vous le voyez sur ces images trois
ministres du gouvernement sont arrivés
pour lancer les célébrations du 40e
anniversaire du tgv le chef de l'état
emmanuel macron devrait arriver dans
quelques minutes et dévoiler le nouveau
tgv le tgv m le tgv du futur comme on
l'appelle là un certain nombre de
personnes se sont rassemblées autour
d'une rame de tgv justement et on attend
donc l'arrivée du chef de l'état il y à
40 ans quasiment jour pour jour le fun
de septembre 1981 le tgv dans cette
danse est admis au rang je faisais sa
première connexion entre paris et la
ville de lyon en 2h40 à l'époque contre
quatre heures avant que le lancement du
tgv je vous conseille en cette journée
particulière
d'aller jeter un oeil sur lefigaro.fr et
vous voulez lire les archives du figaro
les archives du figaro ont rouvert un
article et ont remis en ligne un article
pour les internautes du figaro
c'était le voyage commercial lors du
voyage commercial inaugural de cette
première ligne à grande vitesse reliant
paris et lyon est bien le figaro s'était
glissé parmi les heureux passagers et
donc on peut relire l'expérience vécue
donc par les passagers à l'époque et
avec un verbatim qui sert de titre à ce
papier cet élégant s'est soigné disait
un voyageur à l'époque donc aller
voyager avec les passagers du premier
tgv en septembre 1981 donc sur le site
du figaro et la page histoire avec cette
archive du figaro on va peut-être
ce que j'étais en direct allez-y
françois de choses important d'abord
d'abord on voit monsieur cracovie de
sylla qui parle donc c'est le patron de
sncf voyages
il faut savoir que la sncf a ses entrées
au gouvernement parce qu'il ya deux
ministres très important du gouvernement
qui ont précédemment travaillé la sncf
c'est madame bornes et madame par les
eaux et florence parler aux armées vous
voyez que la sncf est quand même
quelque chose qui est très bon et un
vivier un ministre c'est ça mais je veux
dire que l'essai le set est très proche
de l'état
et puis
ce que dit justement le patron de la
sncf transports mais aussi à gages
[Musique]
il et
en lieu éco responsable ouvert à tous
j'ai aperçu beaucoup de personnalité ils
sont avec nous qu'ils sont avec vous les
premières personnalités que je voudrais
saluer ce sont les agents sncf il y en a
qui sont en verre ce sont ceux et celles
qui vont vous guider et qui vont vous
permettre d'aller cheminer dans toutes
les animations et celles qui sont en
bleu les biens elles vous parlent de
leur métier de leur passion et de leur
expertise
alors qu'on entend de la musique et
l'ambiance est plutôt festive les gens
attendent et le public attend l'arrivée
du chef de l'état pour cette journée
d'inauguration et de lancement des
célébrations du cac 40 ans du tgv on
entend comme je vous le disais de la
musique on vient de voir l'intervention
du patron de la sncf voyages qui salue
les personnels de la sncf on a vu
l'arrivée il ya quelques minutes a
souhaité la bienvenue
de plus le maire et de jean baptiste
jebbari trois tonneaux le verdict de
présents en cette journée particulière
françois des lettrages je me tourne de
nouveau vers vous on lit beaucoup dans
la presse ce matin que le tgv a changé
la vie des français est ce que c'est le
cas selon vous c'est qui le tgv c'est
que le tgv a eu un énorme avantage c'est
que j'exerçais si la sncf a décidé de ne
pas faire uniquement du paris lyon mais
deux que la ligne à grande vitesse
servent de tronc commun et qu'après ça
le tgv tous à lui sur plein de lune
différence
le seul problème de tout ça pour la sncf
aujourd'hui c'est que
le fait de rouler sur les voies est
devenu très cher et quand vous achetez
un billet sur la sncf de rouler sur une
voie ça coûte le prix de rouler sur la
voie correspond à environ 30% du prix du
billet ou parce que vous payez alors
qu'à l'origine quand le tgv a commencé
le coût de la de la location de la voix
coûté quasiment rien donc ça c'est une
donne qui a énormément changé les choses
et la problématique à la sncf
aujourd'hui c'est que par exemple quand
un train fait
du paris nancy il est plein jusqu'à
nancy et après ça quand il va continuer
jusqu'à epinal il ya les deux tiers des
passagers qui vont descendre à nancy et
le travail continue jusqu à epinal avec
seulement un tiers de passagers dont 4
dans ce tronçon la nuit il perdra de
l'argent et donc là c'est vraiment
compliqué pour la sncf qui aurait plutôt
tendance à vouloir
ce que les tgv ne fasse que du poi
points de grande ligne à de grandes
villas grandes villes la problématique
pour les passagers aujourd'hui c'est que
les passagers n'aime pas les
correspondances et que c'est compliqué
de faire une correspondance et que deux
et que deuxièmement les correspondances
vont devenir de plus en plus compliqué à
cause de la concurrence aujourd'hui si
vous prenez un train il va de paris à
bordeaux et qu'après ça vous prenez un
ter qui va de bordeaux à agen vous êtes
obligés d'avoir deux billets un billet
qui est émis par la sncf et un billet
qui est émis par la région
donc c'est très compliqué pour les
passagers
en plus la réduction que vous avez avec
votre carte
avantage ou votre carte liberté elle va
jusqu'à de paris à bordeaux et elle est
plus valable de bordeaux à agen si vous
prenez le ter donc vous voyez que les
correspondances pour les passagers c'est
très très très compliqué et que là il ya
seule l'intervention de l'état qui
pourra faire en sorte que le tgv
continue à aller de bout en bout de ce
que pense l'autre chose qui est très
sympathique très importante et que
défend beaucoup la fnaut de la fnts et
la fédération nationale des usagers des
transports ciation d'usagers de
transports elle dit et avec raison
un tgv qui va de paris à
béziers
il s'arrête à nîmes ou de paris à
montpellier il s'arrête à nîmes à nîmes
il ya 30 % des passagers qui descendent
et donc le train se vide d'un tiers et
la flo 10 mai puisque le tgv se vide un
tiers pourquoi est ce que les passagers
qui ont habillé thé vert n'aurait pas le
droit de monter dans le train pour aller
jusqu'à montpellier alors il ya un
exemple où c'est maintenant le cas la
région hôte france a signé un pacte avec
la sncf pour que les passagers ter
puissent prendre les tgv en bout de
ligne mais c'est quelque chose qui doit
se faire de plus en plus et ça ça
permettra à terme de garder des tgv de
bout en bout vers des plus petites
villes
valent pas eu 34 sur lefigaro.fr
évidemment met en avant un point qui est
souvent soulevée par des voyageurs de la
sncf mécontents et des voyageurs du tgv
va pas eu 34 donc je cite pour garder
des marchés il faut de la régularité de
la qualité de la propreté et les prix
c'est un combo effectivement un certain
nombre de deux points mais qui sont
souvent pointées du doigt justement par
les voyageurs mécontents
alors l'internaute a tout à fait raison
c'est la combinaison de ces points là
qui font que
c'est
le passager vient alors tant que
l'assiette est un monopole le passager
n'a pas n'a pas le choix mais le jour où
il y aura de la concurrence qui elle
sera à l'heure
ça détournera beaucoup de passagers d'un
d'un point à l'autre alors il faut
savoir que sur les passagers il ya deux
cas de figure il ya les passagers
loisirs qui sont très sensibles à la
ponctualité à la propreté etc il ya les
passagers business qui sont peu
sensibles aux prix mais qui sont encore
plus sensibles à la ponctualité donc là
la sncf est devant un cas de figure
difficile à savoir qu'elle a beaucoup
beaucoup de passagers loisirs elle a peu
de passagers
elle a peu de passagers affaires on
reviendra sur la problématique des
passagers à faire mais pour les
passagers loisirs la problématique du
prix est essentielle et c'est pour ça
qu'ils essayent à tout prix de mettre en
avant leur carte avantages et monsieur
farandou a encore dit y'a pas longtemps
et nous ferons une vérification pour le
figaro sur ce sujet là
en disant que la carte avantages c'est
la fin des prix cher c'est pas vrai la
problématique de la sncf c'est que le
tgv a une image de prix cher et le i ce
qu'on appelle le yield management qui
fait augmenter les prix au fur et à
mesure du remplissage du train et 202
jours de départ
la sncf avait fait le choix d'augmenter
les prix dans l'algorithme qui fixe les
prix avaient fait le choix il ya
quelques années
d'augmenter les prix en fonction du jour
du départ quel que soit le remplissage
du train contrairement à l'avion air
france qui ne module ses prix
essentiellement par rapport au
remplissage de l'avion donc on s'est
retrouvés parfois avec des tgv qui
étaient vides avec des prix hors de prix
parce qu'on a acheté son billet trois
jours avant donc ça c'est une vraie
problématique pour les sens' est qu'elle
est en train de corriger la la la
sa difficulté aujourd'hui c'est qu'elle
retourne dans le panneau de la non
flexibilité c'est à dire qu'en seconde
classe par exemple la sncf vous ne
pouvez pas acheter un billet flexible
sans frais vous êtes obligés d'acheter
un billet flexible avec une réduction
mais qui nous sera taxée de 15 euros de
plus si vous changez de train dans les
trois jours qui précèdent le départ avec
un réajustement tarifaire donc vous
voyez pour le phénomène prix petit prix
et c'est là il ne s'est pas encore du
chemin à faire
et par rapport à la ponctualité qu'on
reproche souvent aux tgv dont on parlait
tout à l'heure mais finalement par
rapport aux causes mise en avant par
vous stéphane et les traces pour
justifier ces retards du tgv les
concurrents de la sncf qui seront amenés
à circuler sur ces voies elles vont se
retrouver finalement face aux mêmes
contraintes et les retards seront les
mêmes du côté de la concurrence non oui
elles sont les mêmes du côté de la
concurrence à ceci près qu'ils auront
peut-être une organisation plus où
il est il est pas rare que des trains
sont en retard parce que le ps ou le
disais tout à l'heure le personnel n'est
pas là donc la sncf va lancer une grande
campagne il ya quelques temps qui avait
fait rire tout le monde en disant oui il
faut que le premier train parte à
l'heure pour que le premier prince le
premier principe partent à l'heure c'est
pas une problématique de voix de suicide
était terrassé une problématique
d'organisation interne qu'il faut que le
train qui part à 6 en train de la gare
du l'on soit prêt pour 6 heures 30 de la
gare de lyon viennent de son garage avec
le personnel et partent à l'heure pour
que ce train là qu'il va faire x
rotations dans la journée soit soit à
l'heure donc vous voyez elle est dans
une problématique de fond en terme de
ponctualité qui s'est amélioré ces
derniers temps je dois dire
on va citer quelques chiffres clés
quatre cent mille personnes circulent
dans les tgv chaque jour en france
575 km heure c'est le record de vitesse
battus par par un tgv lors d'un essai en
2007 mais comme disait et nous préciser
françois de l'e3 ça n'est évidemment pas
la vitesse de croisière des tgv lorsque
vous circulez d'une ville à une autre en
france on est plutôt aux alentours de
300 320 kilomètres heure c'est safran
soit non non moi moi moi
invité en vitesse de pointe sur un
trajet commercial on
peut aller jusqu'à 310 300 morts
dans les nouveautés gc ca il ya des
écrans et le train il est souvent aux
260 et 300
c'est déjà pas mal oui c'est pas mal ce
n'est pas mal mais il faut savoir quand
même que avec la technologie moderne on
pourrait faire rouler des trains à 200
km/heure sur des voies normales donc
vous voyez que le gain par rapport à
l'investissement en prenant l'exemple du
pape du paris toulouse du pardon du
bordeaux toulouse
le gain que ça va représenter de
construire une ligne normale sur les
quelques dizaines de clients passant à
quelques kilomètres qui séparent
toulouse 2-2 bordeaux va être colossal
par rapport à l'amélioration de la ligne
existante avec des trains que pouvant
rouler à 200 kilomètres/heure mais le
problème qui est qu'on a en france c'est
que les politiques ne veulent pas en
entendre parler
on peut prendre l'exemple de la ligne s
par exemple sur eux sur metz et nancy on
a créé cette lie l est sous-exploité la
ligne la ligne à grande vitesse donc on
allait l'état a fait des investissements
colossaux pour construire une ligne qui
est sous-exploité et la problématique de
la création de la ligne à grande vitesse
vers metz nancy etc c'est qu'il ya plein
de gars plein de
deux villes qui sont beaucoup moins bien
desservis châlons en champagne bar le
duc tools etc etc donc voyez il ya un
avantage au tgv il ya aussi un énorme
inconvénient pour la desserte des
territoires si je voudrais en bien si je
vous comprends bien il ya un
développement de certaines lignes à
grande vitesse qui sont sous-exploitées
aujourd'hui qui coûte beaucoup d'argent
et mais dont les investissements se sont
fait au détriment de certaines autres
lignes qui pourrait être plus rentable
mais pas forcément des lignes à grande
vitesse
non je sais pas exactement ça la
création des lignes à grande vitesse
sont parfois sous-exploité les lignes à
grande vitesse on parle poisson explique
t on prend l'exemple de strasbourg et de
metz nancy
alors la voie normale n'était pas
n'était pas n'était pas complètement
saturé donc on a créé une ligne à grande
vitesse pour aller vers metz et nancy
elle est sous-exploité donc
l'investissement de l'état par rapport à
la rentabilité de ce que payent la sncf
pour utilise à vous de la voix la ligne
ne sera jamais rentable en revanche
l'ancienne ligne intercités qui passait
par châlons en champagne bar le duc
pagny sur moselle etc
elle est sous-exploité mais les clés les
gens qui habitaient dans ces territoires
ont perdu énormément de desserte que
faisait les lignes à grandes lignes les
grandes lignes autrefois et qui sont
aujourd'hui reprises par des ter qui
roulent très lentement mais c'est
souvent comme un reproche qui est fait
c'est souvent le reproche qui est fait à
parmi les critiques qui sont faites au
tgv c'est c'est d'avoir bénéficié
d'investissements massifs et que en
parallèle et bien et certaines lignes
ferroviaires qui aurait dû subsister ou
qui devrait fonctionner normalement mais
elles sont un peu à bout de souffle
aujourd'hui par manque de moyens et
d'entretien
c'est toute la problématique de la
france où on a mis tout l'argent dans la
création de lignes nouvelles qui ont
coûté des milliards d'euros et que
pendant près de trente à quarante ans on
a délaissé l'entretien des lignes
normales et aujourd'hui on est en train
d'essayer de corriger le tir mais il ya
on a un tel retard qu'il faut des cds
milliards d'investissements pour que les
lignes normales retrouvent leur la
vitesse qu'elles peuvent avoir par
rapport au tgv
d'autres chiffres clés alors qu'on voit
sur ces images diffusées en direct
depuis la gare de lyon le public qui
s'est massée devant une rame de tgv
stationné en gare en gare de lyon je
vous rappelle que nous commentons ce
matin en direct depuis cette gare de
lyon les célébrations du 40e
anniversaire du tgv qui est parti de la
gare de lyon à paris vers la ville de
lyon en province le 22 septembre 1981
inauguré par françois mitterrand à
l'époque et aujourd'hui c'est emmanuel
macron qui devrait lancer ses
célébrations pour ce 40e anniversaire
donc depuis la gare de lyon on a vu il
ya quelques minutes l'arrivée de trois
ministres du gouvernement le ministre
des transports jean baptiste djebbari
bruno le maire -ministre de l'économie
et barbara pompili ministre de
l'écologie ces trois ministres sont
désormais présents sur place on a pu
voir un discours sans l'entendre ah bah
je vois le chef de l'état qui arrive
emmanuel macron donc qui arrivent et qui
devrait dévoiler
normalement la le nouveau tgv le tgv du
futur le tgv m dont une maquette
à taille réelle
est exposée normalement dès aujourd'hui
pour le public en cette gare de lyon
on voir si oui constaté les traces on
peut peut être parler de la
problèmatique but et j'ai aujourd'hui
qui est très importante
quand le tgv a été créé le je
m'arrêterai un des plus président
parlera d'abord
dans le tgv est et que je disais tout à
l'heure c'est que le coût du passage sur
les voies qui n'était pas grand chose
donc le tgv a été très rentable pour la
sncf qu'elle pouvait se permettre de
faire des étoiles c'est à dire d'aller
jusqu'à lyon et puis après ça d'aller
vers grenoble jamais jusqu'à nancy est
pressé d'aller vers les finales de
saint-dié la l'hévéa à droite à gauche
le globe le l'état voulant diminuer le
l'endettement de la sncf a fait un deal
avec leighton s'est pas savoir qui se
disent ils ils lui enlever de la dette
mais en revanche ils augmentaient les
péages sur les sur les lignes à grande
vitesse et l'augmentation des péages sur
la ligne à grande vitesse avec le tgv
n'est rentable que si les plains c'est
dire que s'il fait le plein de passagers
à partir du moment où un tgv perd un ou
deux tiers de ses passagers dans une
gare il n'est plus rentable dans la gare
pour aller dans la garde puisque la
problématique de l'invention du tgv sur
une grande ligne à grande vitesse et
après ça bâtit de la gestion des lignes
normales et mais remise en cause
aujourd'hui alors c'est un c'est un
moment très fort le fait que notre
président de la république soit soit
avec nous ce matin prouve bien que il ya
un engagement fort de l'état de la
france et que tgv c'est le rayonnement
de la france des territoires
l'innovation l'inclusion je vais donner
la parole avant de vous laisser la
parole monsieur le président à jean
pierre farandou qui est notre hôte il ya
de la fierté jean pierre farandou il ya
beaucoup d'émotions en ce moment bien
particulier de lancement de génération
tgv 40 ans oui bien sûr d'abord la
première faire cesser d'accueillir le
président de la république qui nous fait
l'honneur d'être avec vous aujourd'hui
pour fêter le 40e anniversaire des tgv
grand honneur que toute la cncef bien
sûr apprécie beaucoup le tgv c'est un
succès commercial incroyable c'est 3
milliards de personnes transportées
depuis 40 ans donc je sais pas si on
aurait pensé ça il ya quelques années en
arrière c'est aussi bien sûr un succès
industriel une réussite industrielle
c'est toute une industrie qui est
derrière avec une entreprise bien sûr
qui a accompagné tous mouvements de
depuis 40 ans et cette génération de ram
les rats monte évoluer au fur et à
mesure de leur lancement on va te faire
découvrir le le futur dans quelques dans
quelques minutes et puis ces deux
commandes industrielles s'est 549 rames
commandées par la tjv ces 15 milliards
d'euros injectés dans l'industrie par la
sncf voilà donc c'est bon c'est un peu
tout ça leur tgv on le sait bien les les
quarts sont là pour nous le dira c'est à
transformer la france pour de vrai je
pense que c'est peut-être c'est vraiment
une des politiques publiques qu'elles
puissent transformer la france ces
dernières années et puis ça changer la
vie des français au plan individuel
voilà la relation au travail la relation
la famille des relations aux loisirs a
complètement changé parce qu'on pouvait
traverser la france rapidement et à des
prix accessibles et ans emploi parce que
je le redis c'est tgv populaire qu'on a
voulu faire voilà et ça fonctionne alors
vous connaissez notre slogan on aime
bien ce slogan bleu blanc rouge est
complètement versé presque une campagne
voilà on est on est très fiers de ce
slogan d'abord c'est la france voilà
mais comment elle aime la france
inclusive la france ouverte la france
des lumières c'est la france que nous
aimons et puis complètement vert parce
que le défi climatique il est là on le
sait bien et le tgv ou le ferroviaire
d'une manière générale et à l'évidence
la solution pour réconcilier mobilité
des marchandises aussi et des voyageurs
avaient protection de la planète voilà
donc pour terminer cette courte
introduction 40 ans d'anniversaire on va
souhaiter longue vie au tgv qui ferment
le transport écologique par excellence
en france et en europe parce que le tgv
est là aussi vocation à relier l'europe
merci monsieur pour une merci beaucoup
je demande d'applaudir jean pierre
farandou le président du groupe sncf
monsieur le président merci d'être
d'être avec nous votre présence est un
signal fort on parlait de présence dans
les territoires en parler d'innovation
de france fière qui gagne et qui réussit
et qui exportent
ça fait partie de vos credo est de ce
pourquoi avec votre gouvernement vous
vous battez au quotidien merci beaucoup
merci président pour vos mots est
vraiment salut tout le monde
ce matin je suis extrêmement heureux
d'être d'être parmi vous vous l'avez dit
si nous sommes là tous réunis c'est en
effet une fierté c'est une fierté
industriel président l'a rappelé parce
que c'est le génie français la
technologie française et la capacité
ensuite à produire avec les chiffres
dont vous avez rappelé l'ampleur et
c'est une fierté si je puis dire
historique et d'avenir on y viendra tout
à l'heure mais comme toujours avec la
sncf c'est aussi une fierté humaine
c'est à dire que ce ne sont pas que des
inventions technologiques ou des trains
c'est un collectif de femmes et d'hommes
qui depuis des décennies est d'aller
bâtir avec toute la filière en amont et
les industriels et mais ce sont aussi
celles et ceux qui les entretiennent les
font vivre et permettre à nos
concitoyens
justement dû voyager et je pense que
cette réconciliation c'est ce qui
caractérise en effet l'entreprise le
groupe c ce qui est notre fierté
collective est ce qu on veut continuer à
faire justement un prospérer parce que
derrière ça glee à nos valeurs il ya
l'idée de l'excellence et à l'idée de
l'aménagement du territoire il ya aussi
cette idée que à travers le temps on
passe ce savoir-faire de main en main et
que c'est une histoire de continuité et
on y viendra dans un instant mais les
choix d'avenir auxquels nous procédons
les investissements massifs auxquels
nous procédons qu'il s'agisse d'ailleurs
du réseau ou de l'innovation
industrielle ce sont des choix qui
marque au fond la confiance de la nation
dans ses 40 ans de succès mais plus
largement dans ce qu'est capable de
faire la sncf et avec elle l'ensemble du
monde cheminot donc merci beaucoup et je
suis très très heureux très fier vous
l'avez compris d'être parmi vous ce
matin avec plusieurs ministres du
gouvernement et beaucoup d'anciens
ministres qui marque aussi cette
fidélité à travers le temps et toutes
les sensibilités politiques à l'égard de
la sncf donc merci à vous merci monsieur
le président
notre président de la république
monsieur emmanuel macron qui a parlé de
cette saga et de toute cette chaîne
humaine de compétences et d'innovation
depuis 40 ans
si vous nous rejoignez en direct sur
figaro l'arrivée sur la chaîne figure
relève youtube nous sommes en direct
depuis la gare de lyon où
le chef de l'état emmanuel macron vient
de lancer les célébrations du 40e
anniversaire du tgv on célèbre
effectivement cette année un les 40 ans
du tgv le 22 septembre 1981 le tgv 7 ce
train orange faisait sa première
connexion entre la gare de lyon à paris
et la ville de lyon en province en 2h40
au lieu de 4h à l'époque on vient
d'entendre le pdg de la sncf jean pierre
farandou qui a ensuite passé la parole à
emmanuel macron qui a parlé de fierté
industriel historique et d'avenir en
parlant du tgv est qui a aussi parlé
d'un succès de 40 ans françois des les
traces vous êtes journaliste au figaro
magazine avec nous depuis une heure
maintenant pour répondre aux internautes
et commenter ses 40 ans du tgv est ce
que ça a toujours été un succès ce tgv
est ce qu'il n'a jamais été remis en
cause un certain moment
il est remis en cause maintenant il s a
toujours été un succès parce que le tgv
s'est toujours présenté sur des lignes à
fort trafic
quand il a été créé sur paris union il y
avait une grosse qu'on peut avec quatre
heures avec quatre heures de temps de
transport entre lyon et paris il y avait
à l'inter avait beaucoup d'avions qui
faisait orly lyon
le jour où le tgv a mis 2 heures ou deux
heures et quart pour faire paris lyon
évidemment le
le public s'est
déportée de l'avion vers le train et
comme la ligne entre lyon et paris
étaient saturées la sncf ne pouvait pas
rajouter trop inquiéter tout le temps
plein elle avait même des trains sans
arrêt de lyon à paris pour essayer de
gagner un quart d'heure qui était mais
archi comble donc du coup du jour au
lendemain en mettant moins de deux
heures c'était un tapis rouge pour le
tgv puisqu'il il a tout de suite gagné
ses parts de marché et son public quand
on a ouvert ensuite marseille il ya eu
zéro problème puisque maël la ligne sur
marseille avignon etc
c'était c'était très très très plein
mais quand on est en guerre bordeaux et
c'est une cfa 10 mois avec dix huit
allers-retours par jour jeune j'ai assez
et on l'a obligé à en faire 32 pourquoi
est ce qu'on l'a obligé à faire 32 c'est
parce que
l'économie de la ligne n'aurait pas été
rentable celle de la voix n'aurait pas
été rentable si l'asn avait prié de
prendre de redevances pour aller jusqu'à
lyon donc lé an chez rough reçurent lyon
sur bordeaux et on n'est pas du tout sûr
qu'elles gagnent de l'argent sur le
paris bordeaux
vous voyez il ya une problématique à la
fois devoir de d'offres demande de
passagers et de culte est ce qu'on peut
considérer aujourd'hui que le tgv est
une machine rentable une entreprise
rentable
alors ça a été la vache à lait de la
sncf pendant des années ça l'est de
moins en moins maintenant pourquoi celle
de moins en moins c'est ce qu'on dit
depuis tout à l'heure c'est le prix de
fer ou le coup de faire rouler un tgv
sur une voie est de plus en plus cher et
représente aujourd'hui
30 % du prix du billet donc du coup de
la csn ne pouvant pas augmenter ses prix
à l'infini elle a déjà été obligées
d'augmenter ses prix elle a essayé de ne
pas augmenter mais elle est obligée à
cause du grand chef du renchérissement
de la tva dont vous voyez que l'état est
pas trés et pas très clair avec le train
d'un côté il dit il faut que le train
soit pas cher il faut que ceux-ci faut
que cela or i logo il fait augmenter le
pot luck août
du passage du train sur une voie et d'un
autre côté il augmente la tva donc vous
voyez vous voyez qu elles
ont beau défendre
le train ils
jouent après sur tous les tableaux et là
on sait qu'on s'interroge aussi un set
cette présence du chef de l'état du
gouvernement en partie aujourd'hui cette
mise en avant du train à grande vitesse
et ces nouvelles rames qui vont être
mises sur les rails en 2024 cancer
france et et qu'en pense l'avion sur le
territoire français comment va se
positionner air france désormais
alors la sncf a fait l'erreur pendant
des années qu'elle est en train de
corriger de vouloir à biot knees et le
tgv est de penser que le tgv c'était le
concurrent de l'avion et donc elle est
dans un processus de fixation des prix
de changement de billet exactement comme
comme si c'était de l'aérien et elle
perd des passagers
à cause de toutes ces restrictions qui
se détournent vers la voiture donc
aujourd'hui la snci ça va bien compris
que sa problématique c'était pas l'avion
c'était la voiture on va prendre un
exemple tout simple sur paris
montpellier
un tgv à ce qu'on appelle en unités
multiples c'est-à-dire un double tgv
c'est 1000 passagers un airbus a320
d'air france et 170 passagers vous vous
voyez qu'on n'est pas du tout dans le
bape dans la même catégorie même si en
france avait dix vols par jour ça
représenterait un tgv et demi donc ça
n'a rien à voir donc donc la bagarre
contre l'avion était d'une bagarre
qui ne sert à rien en revanche de se
bagarrer contre la voiture ça c'est une
vraie vraie vraie question est là et
c'est cette ne se donnent pas les
éléments de se bagarrer quand pour la
voiture pour une raison toute simple
c'est que c'est compliqué de changer de
vie y est c'est parfois compliqué
d'acheter un billet et c'est parfois
cher quand on est plusieurs donc c'est
cette problématique lac licensed doit
corriger au fil du temps pour que les
gens délaissent la voiture et prennent
vers le train qu'il faut savoir que la
voiture est plus polluante que l'avion
est beaucoup beaucoup plus polluant que
le train est-ce qu'il va y avoir à
propos de l'avion une volonté de réduire
encore les vols en avion sûr sur les
lignes aériennes au dessus de la france
alors il ya eu le deal complètement
ridicule de dire que à moins de 2 heures
40 il fallait plus de liaisons aériennes
qu'est-ce qui est ce qui est n'importe
quoi on va prendre l'exemple de bottes
de bordeaux de bordeaux orly l'aéroport
de bordeaux il est à mérignac donc il a
une zone de jeu chalandise qui est pas
du tout la même que la gare de
centre-ville de même il arrive à orly et
la zone de chalandise d'orly et pas du
tout la même que celle de la gare de
lyon donc
obligé dépasse les quelques passes les
quelques centaines de passagers par jour
qui allait de mérignac à orly à prendre
le train pour aller de bordeaux centre à
gare de lyon ça n'a aucun intérêt
donc donc ça c'est vraiment on est
vraiment dans la politique pure et
simple de dire la planète la planète la
planète alors qu'en fait un passager qui
à mérignac il va aller qui valait au
centre de lyon qui va arriver à paris
gare de lyon qui après ça reprendra un
taxi pour aller sur le plateau de saclay
on va consommer plus ou émettre plus de
co2 que s'il avait pris l'avion entre
mérignac et orly donc vous voyez on est
vraiment dans des problématiques
compliqué alors il ya le phénomène de un
peu en train de prendre de l'ampleur en
disant oui il faut supprimer l'avion sur
toutes les liaisons qui sont à 4 heures
sauf que ça c'est une hérésie une
hérésie économique le trafic affaires en
avion c'est essentiellement des gens qui
font des trajets journée ces deux
équipes partent le matin qui rentrent le
soir
faire ça avec adepte des tgv à 4 heures
c'est pas possible
france ou des états on peut aussi se
questionner aujourd'hui sur le transport
de marchandises le fret ferroviaire on
en est ou sur cette question là qui a
animé beaucoup les débats c'est ces
derniers temps et qui revient
régulièrement sur le devant de la scène
on va dire est ce que oui ou non
moment donné on va avoir un
développement un peu conséquent du
trafic commercial non plus sur les
autoroutes et par camion mais sur les
voies ferrées en france
alors la première problématique c'est
pas d'augmenter le trafic fret c'est
qu'ils ne baissent pas
excusez moi pour le raccourci mais c'est
vraiment la problématique à savoir que
le fret représente à peine 10 % du
trafic marchandises aujourd'hui et que
donc si on arrive à skhirate garde 10%
et que peut-être un jour il passe à 13
ou 14% on aura une grande victoire il ya
deux trois choses qui marchent bien en
ce moment c'est ce qu'on appelle des
autoroutes ferroviaires c'est à dire des
ddd train de marchandises qui partent
d'un point avec des containers au nord
de la france et qui vont vers le sud de
la france
qui transportait containers truc temps
donc là ils ont mis au point une
technologie qui marche bien et qui est
plébiscitée donc est-ce que ça c'est
l'avenir de demain ce qu'on a presque on
ne résoudra pas c'est le
sait dans une entreprise qui est loin
d'une voie ferrée et qui va livrer des
marchandises à une autre entreprise qui
est loin d'une voie ferrée c'est très
très compliqué en plus le la route c'est
comme pour les passagers est là une
souplesse que n'a pas le train quand
vous êtes en voiture et que vous décidez
de partir à 10 heures et que vous avez
un aléa vous partez à 11 heures c'est
pas très grave si vous avez un billet de
train 10h et que vous loupez votre train
c'est toute une histoire pour prendre le
suivant et pas pour le fret c'est la
même chose
merci françois del et rase pour votre
expertise sur le train à grande vitesse
et merci encore d'avoir répondu à nos
internautes ce matin nous étions en
direct
depuis la gare de lyon ou été lancé par
le chef de l'état les célébrations du
40e anniversaire du tgv je vous rappelle
que le tgv à 40 ans beaucoup d'entre
nous se souviennent peut-être on peut le
voir sur les images si la régie veut
bien nous montrer les images d archives
de ce tgv dont on se souvient qu'ils
étaient orange il a fait son premier
déplacement commercial en tout cas entre
commercial oui je crois qu'il y avait
des vraies passagers à l'époque le 22
septembre 1981 ils partaient de la gare
de lyon à paris et à destination de la
ville de lyon il avait été inauguré par
françois mitterrand mais on va préciser
qu'il avait été lancé par pompidou
georges pompidou à l'époque construit
sous le président valéry giscard
d'estaing et donc inauguré par françois
mitterrand voilà on voit ces images
d'archivés
qui montre là la machine tgv telle
qu'elle était à l'époque avec les
conducteurs et ces images où on avait
évidemment
cette sensation de vitesse déjà on
écoutait tout à l'heure un internaute
qui nous disait à quel point c'était
plaisant de voyager en tgv puisqu'on
avait l'impression non pas de rouler
mais de glisser sur les voies ferrées
avec le tgv on le voit là c'est une
pointe à 380 km heure si je me trompe
pas sur l'écran qu'on voyait dans cette
archive
lefrançois de letras quand vous voyez
ces images
c'est vrai que vous interroger au début
de ce direct est-ce que vous avez
souvenir de ce train tel qu'il était à
l'époque dans cette couleur orange est
ce que vous avez vous même voyagé à
l'époque dans ses rames
j'ai voyagé dans ces rames parce que je
faisais souvent paris lyon et que donc
du coup c'est vrai que ça a gagné un
temps mort en monstre c'était c'était
extraordinaire
l'allier les relations entre lyon et
paris ont changé grâce au tgv il faut le
reconnaître
mais il faut moduler ce que disait
monsieur a rendu tout à l'heure c'est
que si le tgv a modifié la france il l'a
modifié pour un certain nombre de
français et il l'a modifié dans le
mauvais sens pour un
autre nombre de français important parce
que du coup il ya un certain nombre de
lignes secondaires ou deux lignes
intercités qui ont été beaucoup moins
bien exploité que ce qu'elles étaient
avant l'arrivée du tgv
il faut soit passer toujours dans la
notion de territoire
le tgv c'est fait pour les grandes
métropoles alors je vais vous donner un
jeu vous raconter une histoire qui est
quand même très intéressant quand le tgv
paris marseille a été créé l'essai de la
sncf réseau qui s'appelait pas comme ça
à l'époque avait demandé à la sncf que
tous les tgv s'arrête au moins à un
endroit sur le parcours pour qu'ils
aient tous le même temps de parcours
c'est à dire une fois à mâcon une fois à
montchanin une fois à lyon une fois à
valence une fois à avignon etc etc et la
sncf avait refusé parce que elle avait
son ambition c'était d'aller le plus
vite possible de paris à marseille donc
elle était vraiment dans une logique
concurrence avec la navette d'air france
sur marseille alors que
raisonnablement elle aurait dû s'arrêter
en route alors il ya encore des
maintenant il ya des tgv qui s'arrête
mais il ya des par exemple à mâcon en
pleine bourgogne vous pouvez pas prendre
un tgv pour aller à marseille il ya 25
qui passe par jour il y en a aucun qui
s'arrête à mâcon donc voyez dans la
notion de territoire
et d'aménagement du territoire le tgv ne
remplit pas son rôle en tout cas le
résultat est l'ailé les bénéfices
économiques n'ont pas n'ont pas la même
portée qu'on soit effectivement à
bordeaux on parle beaucoup de bordeaux
est de l'explosion immobilière d'aidé du
marché immobilier à bordeaux où qu'on
soit à mâcon
mais lorsqu'il ya une donnée technique
aussi qui est important c'est que quand
le tgv s'arrête dans une gare tgv il
perd 7 minutes
quand un tgv s'arrête dans une gare non
tgv comme c'est le cas sur le sur paris
bordeaux où on n'a pas créé de cartes
déjà vu mais donc il reprend la voie
normale il va en ville et rejoint la
ligne à grande vitesse il perd 13
minutes donc vous voyez que sur le temps
de parcours de multiplier les arrêts ça
un handicap sur le temps de parcours
général de la ligne
alors qu'on voit des images d'archivés
du tgv
qui nous sont fournies par la ligne à l
afp on voit les images du tgv en 1981
voilà avec ces images qui donnait
vraiment cette impression de vitesse
on vous a
car lotus une petite parenthèse
ça fait quand même un peu grande nation
vous savez ça fait penser au minitel ça
fait penser à toutes ces choses que la
france a créé tambour battant envers et
contre tous
c'est des inventions françaises alors il
y en a qu il y en a qui ont marché dans
le monde entier il y en a d'autres qui
ont moins bien marché dans le monde
entier celle qui a absolument pas marché
c'est le minitel qui n'a pas décollé et
qui a été remplacé par internet et puis
il ya le tgb qui marche un petit peu à
l'étranger mais qu'il n'y a pas du tout
le succès qu'on imaginait quand on la
construit alors pour quelle raison
d'ailleurs
et parce qu'il ya des les raisons sont
simples mais pourquoi les allemands
n'auraient jamais achetées du tgv
les allemands ils ont une industrie
ferroviaire il voulait créer leur tgv en
plus la conception du ferroviaire entre
l'allemagne et la france est pas du tout
la même en allemagne l'allemagne n'est
pas un pays jacobin elle a pas eu l a
pas une capitale avec 12 millions
d'habitants elle a plein de villes
françois on aurait pu imaginer une
coopération de façon airbus on aurait pu
mais
les deux entreprises qui sont siemens
d'un côté alstom de l'autre était
tellement puissante à l'époque comment
airbus a démarré airs d'airbus a démarré
avec danses étaient la france qui était
chef de file de la faire parce que
l'allemagne n'avait plus d'industrie
aéronautique 1 puisque après la guerre
ils ont eu l'interdiction d'avoir une
industrie aéronautique donc quand on m'a
créé airbus s'était pas la confrontation
de plusieurs poids lourds on avait su
d'aviation à l'aérospatiale en france
qui étaient énormes et les allemands qui
avaient rien donc les allemands ils
étaient tous contents qu'on crée un
airbus européen ça leur permettait de
mettre un pied dans l'aérien pour le
ferroviaire on n'était pas du tout dans
la merde dans le même cas de figure et
les bagarres franco-française et est
allé franco allemande aurait pas permis
de créer un airbus de dix trains et donc
les allemands eux ils avaient une autre
problématique de la france
c'est qu'ils ont beaucoup de villes et
donc il leur fallait un train qui
s'arrêtent souvent qui démarre vite qui
freinent rapidement alors que les jus de
tgv qui démarre lentement efrén
lentement donc oui on avait deux
problématiques très différents dans l'
usage qui ont fait que les amants créé
lycée avec la france a créé les tgv
je ne sais pas si nous avons a de
nouveau des images en direct depuis la
gare de lyon ce matin avait lieu les
célébrations le début des célébrations
du 40e anniversaire du tgv on a pu voir
emmanuel macron faire dire quelques
petits mots en présence du pdg de la
sncf jean pierre farandou à ses côtés
trois ministres barbara pompili benoît
lemaire jean baptiste djebbari
en anniversaire on va dire en grande
pompe en quelque sorte et on a pu voir
parmi les personnes présentes à l'image
on va le préciser parce que à un moment
donné pendant qu'on parlait françois y
avait une dame d'un certain âge habite
tout blanc
simone effectivement il faut le préciser
c'est simone hérault qu'on a pu voir et
c'est la voix de la sncf depuis 40 ans
au départ c'était la voix de la radio
c'est une voix de la radio à fip c'était
une fille pète comme on dit elle avait
passé une audition un sdf en 1981 et
après elle a été engagée comme
comédienne été payés au cachet et elle
ne voyage pas gratuitement faut le
préciser avec la sncf et elle n'avait
pas non plus le statut de cheminot voilà
pour la petite anecdote concernant
simone que les français dans leur
immense majorité ceux qui prennent le
train connaissent pas ce qu on l'a tous
entendu sa voix alors et en plus ce
qu'il faut ajouter c'est que la voix de
simone a été synthétisé au cas où il lui
arriverait quelque chose et que donc
aujourd'hui même si un jour simone n'est
plus là on aura toujours la boîte simone
à la
sncc bien ça
quelques messages d'internautes qui sont
très heureux de revoir le tgv tel qu'il
était à l'époque stricte world 35 sur le
tchat
youtube du figaro j'adore les tgv moi je
trouve cela incroyable et magnifique
super pour voyager et puis eric roux
danault et certains ne le démentiront
pas peut-être ils ont même son point de
vue moi je veux la couleur orange qui
claquent effectivement elle était belle
cette couleur là on aurait bien aimé la
retrouver je ne sais pas quel sera le le
tgv est le futur tgv mais sharon
charlotte elle était si belle qu'il ya
quelqu'un qui n'avait qui l'appliqué
c'est easy jet et que les avions 10 g de
son orange pour être bien visibles et
c'est vrai c'est une anecdote véritable
belle
histoire
bon ben on finira sur sur cette anecdote
là entre le train et l'avion merci
encore de nous avoir suivis en direct
nous étions là pour commenter le
lancement des célébrations du 40e
anniversaire du tgv je vous rappelle que
l avait lieu en la gare de lyon à paris
et on se souvient donc que c'était
exactement le 22 septembre 1981 que le
jeu tgv permis de rejoindre lyon depuis
paris en 2h40 au lieu de 4 heures
auparavant aujourd'hui je crois que ces
deux heures désormais qu'on peut relier
paris à lyon en province merci encore de
nous avoir suivis de nous avoir fait
part de vos commentaires et de vos
questions merci beaucoup à françois de
les traces du figaro magazine de s'être
levés aux aurores depuis le canada pour
échanger avec nous en direct sur figaro
live à bientôt françois merci pour vos
à bientôt sur figaro live